diese Folge pimp my kitchen wird anders
denn normalerweise plane und organisiere
ich ja Küchen für andere Menschen dieses
Mal plane und gestalte ich meine eigene
Traumküche bei pimp my kitchen zeige ich
euch wie man Küchen plant wie man sie
einrichtet wie man sie gestaltet und
teilweise auch wie man mit kleinem Geld
Küchen auch richtig toll aufpimpen und
dekorieren kann also dieses Mal wird's
ganz ganz anders wird richtig toll denn
es ist die Folge pimp my kitchen viel
[Musik]
Spaß
diese studküche hat mich die letzten 5
Jahre jeden Tag begleitet und ich kann
sagen wir haben in dieser Küche wirklich
Geschichte geschrieben hier waren schon
so viele Menschen die mit mir gekocht
und gebacken haben ja ich wusste jetzt
nicht was das ist weil hier ist leider
kein
Sticker bin echt bei meinem Handgelenk
angekommen nein die Torte zählt ich woll
gerade sagen du musst
wissen bastelt wir haben gefeiert wir
waren hier glücklich wir waren traurig
wir waren wir hatten so alle Emotionen
hier in der Küche ich weiß welche Torte
ich nicht mehr Wochen werde
oh wie sehr will sie ausrasten
[Musik]
ja und ich muss sagen ich freue mich
einerseits drauf aber irgendwie sind
schon so bisschen gemischte Gefühle aber
ich bin frei und ich bin offen für
Veränderung und ich freue mich auf eine
schöne neue Küche die ich jetzt
gemeinsam mit Euch planen werde und dann
wird hier drin alles verändert der Boden
die Decke die Wände die Räumlichkeiten
einfach so
alles das sind jetzt so die letzten
Minuten in dieser Küche denn wir werden
jetzt hier die Küche ausräumen und dann
wird sie einmal komplett ausgeräumt
ausgebaut und neue Küche zieht hier ein
noch mal kurz hier zeigen wir sind hier
alle mit geladener Frauen
gebte frauenp m wir schaffen
das jetzt haben wir es geschafft alles
ausgeräumt und morgen wird die Küche
abgebaut Wahnsinn und alles andere ist
hier noch alles verräumt schon
[Musik]
Wahnsinn
s mal muss ich das eigentlich als
Produktplatzierung
kennzeichnen was meint ihr nee oder n n
[Musik]
okay wir sind bei Nobilia in FL auf der
Hausmesse und sammeln Inspirationen für
meine neue
Küche ja B du hier ja ich komme gleich
bist du hier
ja okay ich
[Musik]
komme müssen wir hier jetzt schauen wie
was Studio
planen denn ich fand es eigentlich ganz
schön dass
wir die Insel durchteilen dass wir so
eine kleine und eine große Insel haben
und dann in der Mitte mit einer Theke
kombinieren also h haben wir
190 können wir machen 190 mit Kochfeld
weil Spülbecken haben wir ja hinten
2,50 m
ja denn dann kann man hier schön
ausrollen und wenn man doch was hat wo
man sich so ein bisschen runterbücken
müsste hat man hier noch mal 10 cm
mehr ich glaube sowas mache
ich Co sehr
schönfät mir
gut grün grün grün sind alle meine
Kleider grün grün grün ist alles was ich
hab
darum ich alles was so grün
ist vielleicht wird ja auch meine neue
Küche grün so wie hier Jade Jade ist
nämlich eine neue Farbe in der
sensorfront und es ist wirklich eine
ganz ganz tolle Farbe komm ich zeig euch
[Musik]
mal da will man den ganzen Tag einfach
nur noch frontstreich weil sie so schön
aussieht so weich ist und sich extrem
gut anfühlt
sensoade das ist meine neue studioküche
die nehme ich
mit mit Nobilia könnt ihr aber nicht nur
die Küche gestalten Nobilia stet das
ganze Haus aus wirklich angefangen bei
der Küchenplanung gehen wir weiter zum
Esszimmer in den Wohnbereich
Schlafzimmer Büro Badezimmer es ist
alles fürs Haus da und es ist
wunderwunderschön und deswegen sammle
ich jetzt hier noch Inspirationen für
den Wohn und Essbereich des Studios und
dann zeige ich euch gleich wie ich alles
geplant habe und nicht vergessen Kanal
abonnieren kommentieren und Glocke
[Musik]
aktivieren
alle
[Musik]
wach los geht's jetzt also mit meiner
Küchenplanung ich habe mir jetzt
überlegt dass ich statt einer ganz
großen Kücheninsel einfach zwei geteilte
Kücheninseln mache und damit schaffe ich
dann eben auf der einen Seite eine
Kochzone mit Spüle auf der ich dann
wunderbar Gerichte zubereiten kann und
die andere Insel soll dann quasi ohne
Unterbrechungen sein auf der
Arbeitsfläche und eben eine schöne große
Fläche bieten die rollbare Theke aus
unserer ehemaligen studioküche werden
wir übrigens auch benutzen und da
einfach mit einsetzen denn damit kann
man beide Kücheninseln z.B ergänzen oder
eben sogar optisch verbinden hinter der
Kochinsel befindet sich dann auch direkt
die backzone die mit meinen zwei
Backöfen und einem großen backschrank
ausgestattet ist hier sind dann nämlich
alle Zutaten die ich an meinem
Vorbereitungsplatz neben der Spüle
hinter dem Wasserplatz abwiegen und dort
auch vorbereiten kann so entsteht eben
wieder ein super arbeitsdreieck zwischen
Kochen vorbereiten und spülen und für
mich sogar ein super arbeitsvereck weil
meine backzone mit den backwerkzeugen
auch in unmittelbarer Nähe ist und die
habe ich dann eben auch im mein
greifbarer Nähe ohne viele Laufwege und
die Ecke die habe ich jetzt hier recht
großzügig geplant die wird dann noch mit
den Free Regalen ergänzt damit einfach
ein bisschen Luftigkeit und moderne
reinkommt und trotzdem eben Stauraum
geschaffen wird der dekorativ genutzt
werden kann nebenan auch die Kü und
gefrhkombinationen da ist er dann z.B
Milch mit dabei oder eben frische
Lebensmittel über dem Wasserplatz an dem
sich hier auch der Geschirrspüler
verbindet mit dem mülltrennsystem
befindet sich dann auch endlich genug
Stauraum für Gläser und eben sonstiges
Staugut optisch ist die Küche eigentlich
jetzt fertig aber es kommt hier noch
eine Lagerhaltung mit dazu also
sozusagen ein integrierter
hauswirtschafts bzw Vorratsraum und den
schaffe ich hier indem ich noch
Gleittüren integriere um ein 360° Studio
und Wohnambiente zu gestalten
plane ich den Essbereich jetzt mit einem
ausziehbaren großen Tisch und mit
Stühlen aus der Nobilia Kollektion plus
Stauraum mit Möbeln die perfekt die
gleiche Front in jarde besitzen wie die
Küche und genauso wird auch der
Wohnbereich schön integriert hier kommt
ein Hängeschrank mit rein und ein
Wohnzimmertisch und das ganze wird dann
noch mit Möbeln ausgestattet die das
ganze komplett
machen
[Musik]
Mario und Claudio stehen bereits in den
Startlöchern um die Küche in den
nächsten 5 Tagen aufzubauen aber wisst
ihr was um euch die Zeit zu überbrücken
machen wir jetzt hier einen Cut und ich
werde euch die Küche dann zeigen wenn
sie endlich aufgebaut
ist okay darf ich Mario und Claudio
haben die Küche aufgebaut und ich sehe
sie das erste Mal komplett fertig in
realall life
okay
oh
ja oh mein Gott das ist noch schöner
geworden als in der Planung Muffin
findest du nicht auch ff guck dir an
guck die an das passt einfach ich finde
jetzt haben wir einfach so ein so ein
360° Studio können wir überall dann
könen wir mal hier was Filmen und da und
da hinten das ist schön boah jetzt jetzt
richten wir die Küche ein ich sehe aber
jetzt schon dass wir es nicht schaffen
werden an einem Tag die Küche
einzurichten aber so ein bisschen was
und dann ma ich eh noch ein
küchenorganisationsvideo bis ich mal
alles da habe wo ich das brauche und
dann so eine richtige Ordnung hab Ei ist
das schön ich Hool mal alles dann richt
mal jetzt
[Musik]
ein ich würde mal sagen herzlich
willkommen in meinem neuen Studio
herzlich willkommen in meiner neuen
Traumküche kommt her rein also hier
kommt man auch als Gast in unser Studio
meine Gäste ziehen hier generell dann
ihre Schuhe aus bekommen von uns
Hausschuhe und kommt dann hier ganz
gemütlich in unserem Eingang an und ich
muss sagen der Eingang war vorher so ein
bisschen dunkel und düster und jetzt ist
er einfach richtig schön einladend und
sehr sehr wohnlich endlich mit einer
rosanen Couch mit einer richtigen
Wohlfühloase hier fühlen wir uns wohl
und ganzsichtlich auch Muffin die da
unten immer auf dem Teppich schläft und
was ich hier ganz schön finde ist dass
wirklich alles so zu diesem komplett
offenen Raum dazu passt das heißt ich
habe eine Nobilia Küche habe das
Esszimmer von Nobilia und auch den
Wohnbereich gerade so der Schrank weil
einfach alles ein großer Raum ist und
die Küche eben nicht mehr nur eine Küche
ist sondern das Zentrum eines jeden zu
Hauses der Essbereich ist bei uns zum
einen Arbeitsplatz also das sind hier
auch Möbel an denen wir eben tagtäglich
arbeiten meistens sit ich da Tolga Anna
Vivi wer auch immer hier gerade im
Studio mitarbeitet wir denken uns hier
die Rezepte aus wir machen hier
Brainstorming und es ist auch hier
wirklich richtig schön weil wir hier
Platz zum Verstauen haben alles
natürlich in der gleichen Frontfarbe wie
in der Küche aber das erzähle ich euch
ja gleich und vor allem mit einem
richtig tollen extrem großen Tisch den
man in verschiedenen Größen auch bei
Nobilia tatsächlich bestellen kann ich
habe hier nämlich auch die Holzplatte
eichesera die ich auch in der Küche
platziert habe und habe hier einfach
einen Tisch der verstellbar ist jetzt
ist er gerade aufs maximale ausgezogen
man kann den aber auch kleiner gestalten
aber da wir recht häufig viele hier sind
haben wir gedacht machen wir direkt die
auszugsvariante und auch die Stühle sind
aus der neuen Nobilia Kollektion richtig
tolle verschiedene Stühle gibt's mit
verschiedenen Gestellen und
verschiedenen Überzügen und ich habe
mich hier für den entschieden der sich
eben auch dreht sehr bequem ist und auf
dem ist sich einfach richtig gut sitzen
ist also den mag ich wirklich total und
vielleicht habt ihr eben schon darüber
gespickt aber wir haben ja auch das
Studio jetzt richtig schön dekoriert und
eingerichtet und ihr seht vielleicht
auch die zwei Bilder da drüben die habe
ich extra jetzt fürs Studio selbst
gemalt und hergestellt aber das zeige
ich euch ganz gerne in einem anderen
Video gehen wir mal rüber zur Küche oder
würde ich sagen also kommt mal mit hier
drüben geht ja bei uns ins Büro ins
Fotostudio nach oben in den Schnitt das
heißt auch mein Team kommt immer morgens
hier rein und hier haben wir jetzt
zuerst direkt mal den Kühlbereich das
heißt einen großen Kühlschrank das der
Bosch side by side mit French ST mit
dieser schönen matten schwarzen
Oberfläche der einfach schön groß ist
und extrem viel Platz für große Torten
liefert denn ich habe hier in der Mitte
einfach keine strebe die den Kühlbereich
durchteilt sondern habe eine schöne
große Fläche da wird jetzt auch wieder
der John deer Traktor reinpassen die
Torte da würde der Minion reinpassen es
würden einfach alle großen Motivtorten
reinpassen oder eben auch große Platten
die man gerne mal servieren möchte und
jetzt ist er noch leer weil hier noch
keine rezeptvos gedreht wurden aber so
langsam füllt sich alles mit Leben und
mit Zutaten und wir haben hier eine
richtig schöne wohlfül kaffeecke die ist
einfach der Hammer hier ist die
Kaffeemaschine darunter ist alles und
auch darüber was man so für den Kaffee
braucht ist total bequem und man kann
halt hier direkt an der Theke auch
stehen und den Kaffee genießen und das
ist so eine Ecke an der wir uns morgens
jetzt bestimmt immer und auch am
Nachmittag immer sammeln werden zum
gemeinsamen Kaffee und hier sehen wir
jetzt richtig schön das Zusammenspiel
der verschiedenen Farben an den Fronten
ich habe hier die Front senso in matt
einmal hier in Jade und hier in dem
Premium weiß sie ist kratzunempfindlich
sie ist total beständig und ich finde es
ist einfach so eine Farbe die in
Kombination mit Weiß richtig gut
rüberkmt ist eine schöne warme Farbe
sehr modern und trotzdem zurückhaltend
und trotzdem hat man so ein bisschen das
Gefühl da hat sich jemand getraut
einfach bisschen Farbe einzusetzen und
ich habe hier dann die Arbeitsplatte
dazu kombiniert und bevor ich aber über
die Arbeitsplatte spreche will ich euch
sagen dass ich mich wirklich habe
inspirieren lassen von der Hausmesse
nobelia denn ich habe es wirklich gewagt
ich habe hier zwei Kücheninseln vorher
war es ja eine große Kücheninsel was
auch super super schön aussah aber ich
finde durch diese zwei Flächen hat man
zum einen so bisschen eine räumliche
Trennung und man hat aber auch das
Gefühl dass die Küche an sich nicht zu
riesig ist weil man eben auch wenn man
mal hier zusammen kommen will dann noch
ein bisschen enger steht und dann seht
ihr auch hier dass ich gar keine
Steckdosen auf der Oberfläche also auf
der Arbeitsplatte habe ich habe jetzt
hier die Flip das heißt wenn ich die
Steckdose nicht brauche ist alles
geschlossen und wenn ich sie dann doch
brauche kann man schön drauf drücken die
Steckdosen benutzen und später einfach
wieder verschließen und als Oberfläche
habe ich hier auf den Inseln und auch
hier im Hintergrund einfach einen echten
Quarzstein kombiniert der hat auch eine
schöne warme Farbe und vor allem ist
Quarzstein einfach total qualitativ
hochwertig hat eine dünne Steinplatte
die einfach sehr elegant und edel
aussieht sieht und kann trotzdem das
Kochfeld und die spülen flächenbündig
einbauen da hat man eben diese
dreckränder nicht und kann wirklich
immer schön sauber arbeiten hier beim
Kochfeld habe ich wieder einen
multenlüfter von Bosch und ich muss
sagen dass jetzt so über die letzten
fünf bis sech Jahre sich wirklich für
mich auch vor allem rausgestellt hat
dass multenlüfter für mich das Plus
Ultra ist und in Kombination mit unseren
neuen Töpfen z.B mit den Deckeln die
dann die Luft direkt nach unten
auslassen ist es perfekt weil sich der
ganze Dunst und der ganze alles was
überkocht eben gar nicht in der Luft
verteilt direkt vom muldenlüfter
abgezogen wird und das Ganze ist mega zu
reinigen man nimmt das hier nämlich
einfach raus hat hier die Filter mit
dabei die können alle in die
Spülmaschine und dann hat man es immer
sauber und rein und hat eben nicht
dieses ganze
geputz sehr gut und alle fragen sich
jetzt bestimmt wo ist er wo ist der
backschrank der ist im Moment
hier wo ich all meine Vorräte verstaut
habe die ich demnächst noch weiter
auffüllen muss denn bald geht das Backen
wieder richtig los ich sag's euch da
freue ich mich richtig drauf ja und
jetzt habe ich hier hier im Hintergrund
meine zwei Backöfen natürlich auch
wieder Serie 8 von Bosch das sind die
die Carbon Black sind also praktisch ein
voll schwarzes Gerät schwarzer Griff und
die sind einfach der Wahnsinn weil ich
wieder ein Kombigerät habe was
Mikrowelle plus Dampfstoß kombiniert und
das andere Gerät ist ein
voldldampfbackofen das heißt ich habe
die herkömmlichen backofeneinstellungen
und alle Funktionen plus das ganze ist
eben noch ein Dampfgarer ja und dann
kommen wir hier noch mal an ein
Herzstück was sich hier versteckt ihr wi
vielleicht noch dass ich vorher hier die
tafelwand hatte wo vieles untergebracht
wurde und jetzt habe ich hier praktisch
einen Vorratsraum versteckt hinter den
Schiebetüren könnt Ihr zu Hause auch
super integrieren falls ihr sagt ihr
baut gerade neu ihr wollt eine Küche
platzieren habt aber jetzt keinen
separaten Raum dann gibt's hier nämlich
die innraumlösung mit den Schiebetüren
von Nobilia und zwar könnt ihr hier
einen kompletten Arbeitsbereich
verstecken sind wir mal ehrlich die
Küche steht gerne mal voll mit Mixer
Küchenmaschinen mit allen Dingen die man
so braucht Toaster Kontaktgrill und das
sind so Sachen die ich nicht so gerne
auf meiner Arbeitsfläche stehen habe und
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier den Bereich
den ich einfach zuschieben kann wenn es
mir zu viel ist oder auch offen lassen
kann wenn ich gerade dran arbeite weil
auch dieser vorratsbereich einfach total
schön ist ich habe hier nämlich zum
einen auch diese Tarot Designböden ich
habe hier welche die ich für Gläser
verwenden kann aber ich habe hier auch
andere wie beispielsweise hier wo jetzt
bei mir die komplette Vorratshaltung ist
das he hier oben habe ich noch mal die
Designböden die haben hier auch
integriert ein Tablett ein Holztablett
was man dort bestücken kann oder eben
auch direkt mit an den Tisch oder mit in
die Küche nehmen kann hier habe ich auch
noch mal alles in Eich Sierra und was
man hier tun kann das habe ich jetzt
auch ich habe einfach noch mal so zwei
drei ersatzböden denn ich kann
individuell entscheiden möchte ich einen
Holzboden oder möchte ich einen
Designboden und kann dann eben schauen
was mir persönlich so am besten gefällt
hier unten habe ich dann noch ganz
normale Auszüge die man eben in den
Schränken und Auszügen auch hart
platziert so habe ich einfach extrem
viel Platz alles ordentlich und das
werde ich euch natürlich alles demnächst
noch
zeigen ja würde ich sagen habt ihr jetzt
mal so komplett meine Küche gesehen ihr
dürft mir gerne mal schreiben was euch
in dieser Küche am besten gefällt ob
euch die Farbkombination Jade und weiß
super gefällt ob ihr generell mit dem
neuen Studio happy seid denn ich muss
sagen ich find es einfach richtig schön
und diese my kitchen Folge war für mich
die perfekte pimp my kitchen Folge denn
es war pimp my kitchen es ist meine
absolute Traumküche und ich freue mich
drauf ab sofort jeden Tag hier für euch
wieder rezeptvideos machen zu dürfen
Gäste zu empfangen Küche frei zu machen
zu Gast bei sallyi zu machen und einfach
jeden Tag für euch hier Content aus
meiner Welt zu kreieren also vielen Dank
fürs Einschalten wir sehen uns das
nächste mal wieder und bei mir geht's
jetzt hier auch schon direkt
weiter
vergesst übrigens nicht den Kanal zu
abonnieren ein Kommentar dazassen und
auch gerne das Video zu bewerten denn F
my kitchen ist bei uns so ein Format da
blüht jeder auf mein komplettes Team ist
damit dabei und alle sind richtig
richtig happy also bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss so und jetzt machen wir h mal
weiter hallo herzlich willkommen in
sallyis Welt heute gibt's ein ganz ganz
tolles Rezept für euch das zeige ich
euch aber erst das nächste Mal gell
Muffin ja da müsst du nächstes Mal
wieder einschalten also macht's gut ja
komm komm du süße
[Applaus]
Maus